well the days of cuddling America's kids
could be over three Republican senators
in North Carolina introducing a bill
that would ban participation trophies
for children in sporting events so it
reads in part quote Awards provided in
connection with the activities shall be
based on identified performance
achievements but it seems Democrats want
to pamper students even more check out
this newly surfaced clip of Chicago's
left-wing Miralax talking about
abolishing homework and F grades
to be quite Frank with you I didn't
issue a lot of homework for students
that was my own way of sort of rebelling
against the structure
um
I don't think I ever gave a kid an F
I just I don't I don't know how a
student sits in front of you and fails I
know some professors may find that you
know you know it's a slightly troubling
so Dana I think there's a difference
between participation trophies and then
trophies for winners maybe you can have
both for kids well also I think I'm for
limited government and I think this is
you need a bill nonsense and ridiculous
you don't actually need to legislate
anything let parents make this decision
or their schools make the decision of
the teachers whoever and also like if
it's five-year-olds and you're trying to
get everybody to participate in a team
sport I get it everybody gets
participation trophy but I think what
when we make fun of participation
trophies or actually say there's concern
about it is when there's no room for
competition in Merit and winning that
way which is what helps Drive Innovation
and that's where we get into a problem
as for the no homework and the apps I
mean look about two months ago there was
a report out of Chicago public schools
that now nobody could read at grade
level and nobody could do math at grade
level and America's Newsroom producers
called the Chicago public schools for a
comment about this result and they said
we are in line with every other major
Urban School District like as if that
was the defense right right I mean I
imagine that Chicago public schools are
not going to do much better under this
new mayor who is really tied in with the
teachers union yeah I mean Geraldo he's
basically bragging about failing his
students meaning he's not giving them F
so he's saying that they're succeeding
when they're not doing the work well in
in their defense I have to say that
generally speaking a kid getting an F is
from a dysfunctional home home uh
they're they're trying to be remedial I
get the objection to participation
trophies but you want to keep even the
marginal kids engaged and motivated you
don't want to you know tell them they're
going to be failures in life I
understand that it's always a compromise
he seems I don't know this guy the new
mayor of Chicago I wish him well he's
got his hands full but he's dealing with
the you know the the real situation with
cities the cancer crime is certainly it
but it's it's these pockets of poverty
and dysfunction where you don't have a
mom and dad at home that's the root of
it all and I don't know uh I I don't
know that giving that kid a
participation trophy is a bad thing I
think that failing kids is actually a
good thing I remember when I was in
eighth grade this was one of the best
things that ever happened to me at a
history teacher he was the toughest
teacher I ever had I took a test and
didn't do the backside of the test
because I didn't flip the page over so I
only filled out the front and guess what
he failed me so that taught me a big
just on that test I made it up probably
a b or something but the point is that
throughout the next you know test I
flipped the page over and he helped me
succeed Greg by teaching me a lesson
with my own failure you know a lot of
people like to say that you know they
should bring back corporal punishment I
say capital punishment for kids good
idea yeah the um don't get rid of the
participation trophies because then what
what do you give to kids like me I mean
they used to actually it was called back
then it was called most spirited do you
remember that it was like if you could
not if you didn't land one basket for a
three-day tournament I got most spirited
he said land a basket
sink a basket in the in the bowl
but you know um no this is kind of like
a mild reversal of drag queen Story Hour
it's a performative thing yeah it's like
there's a real like why do they it was
like at school you couldn't find
anything else other than drag queen
Story Hour no it was it was a statement
that they're making same here I don't
think you're right I don't think I think
it's a lousy statement it's a waste of
time uh you know
it's obvious that you're do you're kind
of it's a thumb in the eye as for this
like this mayor it goes back to the
thing that they have the they only see
these goals and they don't know how to
get there so they go you know what I
don't want to you know I don't want my
students to get F's well that's a good
goal so his his system is I'm not giving
them no you actually you actually become
a really good teacher and you try to
help them you don't just say I'm not
gonna give out F's that's not a system
that's it that's idiotic and that's the
problem they've decided no more
detention right if they're fights you
can't expel people so and so it's like
when they eliminate crimes and they say
crime is down right so what about this
that's not a system taking challenges
away from kids does not help them
necessarily Jesse Yeah I failed
Shakespeare as a junior and I think that
guy is so overrated he is oh yeah he is
impossible to read and I'm proud of that
F I was really into trophies as a child
I had a mantle in my room and I had all
my trophies set up you still do medals
and everything all my friends it was a
big deal and then one swim meet
I think they gave out a ribbon I don't
know why but I I got fifth place which
I'm still ashamed of in breaststroke I'm
terrible at breaststroke and I couldn't
even hang it
I tried to hide it behind another ribbon
and then I think I burned it in the
backyard in a ceremony this is such an
intriguing story and then it made me a
better swimmer yeah not by getting
better at breaststroke but by quitting
breaststroke and becoming a backstroker
there you go there you go
that's gonna be for our best stuff at
the end of the year
you know what we should do yeah we
should go to your swimming pool where
you started the backstroke do a whole
package
we got speed swimming like speed it up
speeds oh you're being very spirited
about this Craig doing a great job I
went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now